al sur de teherán irán desempleo
explosión de precios en irán bajo
sanciones la economía está desplomada
cuánto cuesta a pesar de su título de
abogado ali de 25 años no puede
encontrar trabajo decepcionado por la
clase política no votará este gobierno
debe garantizarnos cosas simples un
futuro real un trabajo una vida digna
pero no nos da nada entonces no votar en
un punto de vista que está lejos de ser
único no votaré no quiero ayudar a
elegir un mal gobierno
soy inquilino tengo tres hijos y llevo
dos años desempleado los precios están
disparando deje de votar pasan su tiempo
diciendo que mejorará pero nada cambiará
por todas partes en las calles de
teherán se puede ver el retrato del
favorito en las encuestas el conservador
ebrahim raisi es como un videojuego nos
controlan el actor principal cambia de
vez en cuando un día el señor roja ni un
día del señor raíces
un día del señor amarilla cambian eso es
todo somos los jugadores y ellos son los
capitanes
los conservadores esperan una
participación masiva si nadie vota nada
cambiará espero que todos participen en
esta elección de lo contrario es un
regalo para nuestros enemigos las
autoridades temen una abstención récord
el líder supremo el ayatolá alí jamenéi
critica regularmente los llamamientos
para boicotear las papeletas
muhammad y su hermano ali nunca se
pierden ninguno de sus discursos
entiendo que hay quejas pero no puedo
aceptar que esto se convierta en una
excusa para no votar espero que los
jóvenes animen a muchos otros a salir a
votar
una persona religiosa sigo las
instrucciones de nuestro líder supremo
alí jamenéi dice que participar en la
votación es un deber pero muchos no
piensan como yo
durante las elecciones de 2017 más del
70% de los electores acudieron a las
urnas este año según los expertos la
extensión podría ser aún más alta